moment of the sexual experience we'll
ask the young lady who's your dad
if officer akeem
officer officer akimov is here uh that's
beautiful officer
[Music]
i have no idea what's going on
[Music]
i don't know
that was really weird
can you guys still hear me
oh i'm hearing myself coming back that's
weird
are you guys hearing me twice every time
you're not
okay let's try now
okay let's try now no i still didn't i'm
still hearing myself okay okay let's try
now no i still didn't i'm still hearing
myself okay okay let's try now no i
still didn't i'm still hearing myself
okay okay let's try now no i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
okay let's try now no i still didn't i'm
still hearing myself okay okay let's try
now no i still didn't i'm still hearing
myself okay let's try now now i still
didn't i'm still hearing myself okay
let's try it out now i still
i genuinely don't know where that's
coming from
[Music]
hmm
that's so bizarre
let's see if we can get it going now
let's see if we can get it going now
yeah i'm still hearing my own thing
let's see if we can get it going now
yeah i'm still hearing my own thing
now yeah i'm still hearing my own
thoughts
what's going on here yeah i'm still
hearing my own thoughts
what's going on
testing testing
[Music]
testing testing
[Music]
how weird is this
testing one two how weird is this
testing one two how weird is this
testing one two how weird is this
testing one two how weird is this
testing one two however
testing one two however
[Music]
i just don't even know where this is
coming from
i just don't even know
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me now
you can
hmm
but i'm also hearing myself on a delay
that's the weird thing
let me unplug and replug my headphones
okay i plugged in headphones
i'm still hearing myself how is that
possible
monitor is off
doesn't really make any sense
oh wait a second
i this entire time i was watching my
stream in a different tab
oh my god
um who just suggested that i'm that
person that person deserves something
who just said that astro paladin are you
watching your own stream on a different
tab
i was
that's exactly what i was doing
that's exactly what i was doing and i've
ruined the stream
oh my god
what a
fiasco oh my god what a humiliation
well we figured it out guys
we figured it out
dear god what an embarrassment
that was it was the i have a tab going
for ban adjudications
and i was watching my own stream
holy [ __ ]
well listen guys
we're here
okay we're here and uh okay let's look
at super chats first
that was fantastic i love feedback good
sir your audio is up in the air the
feedback is devolving yeah i really
apologize for that i don't even know if
i have my trump
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing right
[Music]
let me recover my ears for once
it's over we figured it out we are here
because joe biden is set to announce a
billionaire's tax
now this is very interesting because it
is not
yeah what's going on now
okay nothing yet
one two three four five yeah
um
this is not going to be a tax on wealth
they are going to use wealth to figure
out whose income to tax and the idea is
if you have a net worth over a hundred
million dollars
you will have to pay a twenty percent
minimum tax
on all income
including unrealized stock gains that's
the idea this is going to explode and
joe biden is set to announce this in
about 20 minutes okay so very very
important stuff
let's get caught up i want to thank some
people who loved the feedback loop
thanks to jen here for signing up and
gifting life is good
rexmo youngest and patty mcninja
putting us at six for the day i really
very much appreciate that i also want to
let you guys know about something else
and this is a really big deal
we still have oh let's do a different
coupon code for today we'll call the
coupon code
let's do obama obama
but we have enabled the gifting of
memberships on our website by popular
demand
you can now select any membership and
check a box which is this is a gift and
you have two options
two yeah
if you have someone specific you want to
gift a membership to you will be
prompted to enter their information or
you can leave that blank and we will
gift the membership to someone
if you want to request a free website
membership go to davidpakman.com
free membership
now i will tell you in order to request
one you do need to be signed into a
google account and because we're
collecting your email address since the
memberships go by email google forms
requires that people be logged in to
google to submit the form i apologize
for that that's just it just is what it
is okay so if you want to gift a
membership when you sign up check the
box that says this is a gift
if you want to receive a membership go
to davidpakman.com free memberships okay
that's the um
that's the gist of it and uh we'll we'll
get it all figured out and i would love
to see
uh i did want to see
sorry it's free membership
davidpakman.com
free membership
and what i want to see here is
whether anybody has already done that
uh just to make sure it's working
free memberships
nobody has done it yet okay we are
accepting responses so if anybody wants
a free membership we can test that
uh and we'll see how um how all of that
is going but very very exciting stuff
you need permission to sign it oh damn
let's see if i can fix that see this is
why we test
this is why we test things
hmm
okay so i might have to i'm gonna have
to work on that
let's see
stricted i need to figure this out
no see the problem is
it's only letting me
edit who can ax who can
i can't let everybody edit the thing
okay we'll we'll have to figure that out
at some other point okay so that's not
working
but we will um we will get to that
okay we're standing by for joe biden to
announce this whole thing real quick
let's get through a few things because i
have some different things going on
first and foremost people who want to be
unbanned um user ropo came here
and even though it had nothing to do
with the kyle rittenhouse trial
the other day
he came in and said
kyle was attacked when you try to blow
up a gas station you're not a victim
just a lot of kyle rittenhouse related
stuff
um
they seem really annoying i think i'm in
a perma-ban okay next
someone here showed up and said stop
muting stop muting it's annoying when
pacman mutes lol stop muting stop muting
okay they were banned the whole point of
watching stuff here is that sometimes i
make comments
so if you don't like it you can go
somewhere else i will unban for now but
just repeatedly put don't mute
and you'll be banned because the whole
point here is that i do commentary okay
um
another user 990
said keep wasting your time in chat
rooms being conditioned by professional
psych crooks that use subliminal
programming science
uh it's conspiratorial
and then they said i'm sorry your
generation can't handle nazi medical
experiments oh okay that's a perma-ban
that's anti-vax insanity
and then robert paulson
said
should we not shun sex offenders
it doesn't matter if he was abused
you're still expected to follow laws if
your childhood is terrible they were
banned
yeah that's an unban i don't know why
they were banned that doesn't make sense
all right so we're two for two on the
unbanned requests fine so we've gotten
that taken care of
um i also want to say thanks to
chief boris
and
dahen g
with the twitch prime subscriptions we
had some massive technical issues at the
beginning of the stream but we're sort
of working through them here
and it is not a bad thing
okay two people gifting subscriptions
kevin combs just gifted a subscription
and ryan anderson just gifted a
subscription on my website that's nine
and ten this is great so the
subscription gifting is working
we'll count those and then the question
will be who do we give them to now
here's the help i need
we created a google form
we created a google form for people to
request free subscriptions
and
nobody has access but when i say share
the google form
it says i need to give them the ability
to edit the form i just want people to
be able to fill out the form so if
anybody understands permissions the
right way to create a google form to to
allow this please email info
davidpakman.com and we'll get it set up
right after the stream okay looks like
they're having some kind of technical
issues here with the lectern very very
unusual stuff going on but that's okay
we're watching it okay um i missed a
bunch of super chats let's see if i can
catch up on some of these david do you
think the will smith punch was staged
you know i thought so for a moment but
now i really don't think so because
everybody reacted as if it was very real
so i don't think it was staged let's
talk about that a little bit
this story has exploded
and um
one of the things i tweeted
this morning
was
i'm having a really hard time caring
about the will smith chris rock thing
can someone give me a hot take i can
pass off on my own
and
the thing about this is
there's like a couple layers here to
what i was doing
first it's like can someone give me a
hot take i can pass off as my own i'm
just kind of kidding around you know
what i mean but what i mean by this is
there's so much strife in the world
right now that i have a hard time
feeling that much one way or the other
about this hollywood drama at the oscars
which i haven't watched in a decade and
a half i just kind of like don't really
care
and this guy pete dominic who i don't i
don't really i don't know pete i mean i
guess he follows me on twitter i don't
know him
he said
i love pacman
but i'm getting i'm seeing a lot of this
from white progressives and white
twitter in general i'm also seeing black
twitter caring a lot about it not a
criticism more of a question now to me
it's strange to categorize me as a
member of white twitter and i had two
reactions to this one was
not a race story if johnny depp slapped
alec baldwin i'd feel the same it's just
hard to relate to out of touch hollywood
when so many crazy things are going on i
also responded
also i'm a hispanic jewish immigrant
from argentina
so i tend to avoid categorizations of
this kind and again this isn't me
denying
that i look white or whatever right the
the point is i don't know why
my comment is being put under the
umbrella of white twitter like what it
just doesn't really make any sense to me
um
and pete dominic said pacman thanks for
the response i really don't have a
strong opinion i'm just seeing and
hearing this is a bigger issue for black
folks
that may be true but it's sort of weird
to ascribe my post about i don't really
care about privileged hollywood elites
slapping each other
to me being
part of quote white twitter
i just found that kind of weird
now in the meantime this is really
strange dave rubin's take on the entire
thing this is called cultural critic
dave rubin
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas
dave rubin
he reacted to what people would have
said
if matt damon slapped someone
i don't know why
um
but but because they know no one's
paying attention would you put it above
the machinery of hollywood to
fabricate something like this that that
chris rock makes a fairly innocuous joke
i mean she's got a shaven head and i'll
talk more about alopecia in a sec as i
said um and that he's going to talk to
us about alopecia will smith so loses
control he's laughing at the joke at
first that he so lost control of himself
that on an evening where he knows
millions even though it's not as many
millions as it used to be millions of
people are watching that he so lost
control of himself that he walks up on
stage comment he didn't bum rush the
stage right he walks up there smacks the
guy and just sits down
no security came and got him uh nobody
you know apparently during the
commercials there were some pr people
saying something to him um but you know
we could also add like the weird woke
element of race to this so it was black
there's a woke element to this i didn't
know that i got black violence which
people obviously treat a little bit
differently i suspect you know when we
whether you talk you know some people
talk about black on black violence in
very bad faith and some people talk
about black on black violence and good
faith
none of them are talking about will
smith slapping chris rock expect that if
matt damon had gotten out of the crowd
very pasty white matt damon had gotten
out of the crowd and smacked chris rock
we'd be there would be riots in the
streets
yes los angeles would have been burned
to the ground if matt damon slapped
chris rock
uh you know so there's a whole series of
things like do you put it past the
hollywood machinery that sort of
seemingly is faking everything all the
time in our culture and our politics
that this might have been staged i don't
know does that make me like a complete
conspiracy theorists no i mean that no i
i also wondered could it have been
staged that's not really the issue i
just don't think we were getting the
rodney king uh uh riots if it was matt
damon doing the slap i just don't
believe that thanks to dirt knapp and
texas bear claw for the twitch prime
subscriptions you can also now gift
subscriptions on our website jody
bundrick has just gifted one and
jennifer devoe has as well we will get
those given to people soon um
in terms of okay can't open a form
all right so let's see here open a form
at the top click settings
we're gonna get this all set up at the
top click settings i don't even see
settings at the top
oh wait a second am i in the wrong
oh settings here we go
responses
clicked it out turn off to restrict
users ah there it is okay beautiful guys
if you want to request a free membership
and right now i have four to give away
go to davidpakman.com
free membership okay
and request a free membership
the first one is going to adam darling
adam has just requested a free
membership beautiful
the second one is going to
adam vega
the third one to sean ross and danny
mcvay gets the fourth okay so we've
given away the four free memberships we
have 17 people want memberships now 23
people want memberships now 29 people
want memberships now 34 people want
memberships
now 35 okay
so listen guys i can only give away as
many memberships as i have to give away
if you want to gift a membership you can
now do it on our website i'll show
people how to do this this is but this
is all by popular demand
actually
i should probably
oh god it's not even working
jesus
it's a mess
something weird's going on here anyway
there's a little box when you sign up
now after you select the membership
which is this membership is a gift
okay if you check it
very good
um
all right so you can gift them on the
website you can request them at
davidpakman.com
free membership we now have 61 people
requesting free memberships
i don't know
it's we're doing the best we can
super chats peter schiff the guy upset
zolensky didn't wear a suit when
addressing congress thinks biden's
billionaire tax is unconstitutional i
don't think it's constitutional but i do
question whether it's politically viable
for sure
i think it's almost
impossible that this tax will become a
reality
but let's let's let's listen to the
proposal first
and then we'll talk about it
thanks to shabibo's mom for gifting two
subs and rsg2
that's 17. i did want to make a memetic
request i would love it if people start
submitting to me david pakman show
related memes using this image this is
the slap image from yesterday
top
um
show related slap memes
will be featured on probably saturday
night we have a big trump rally stream
coming up and if anybody submits some
good um slap memes we will feature them
on saturday so this image i don't know
where you can find this image it's sort
of everywhere uh but it's got to be
somehow related to the show it could be
related to like my reaction when people
call in with that audio it could be real
anything it's all fair game when people
mistype a coupon code there's so many
different ideas but i do want to
encourage people
set up your slap memes and send them to
info
davidpakman.com okay that's the place to
send them
send them
thank you to krange's mcbasketball as
well as hippie chick for the twitch
prime subscriptions numbers 18 and 19.
also thanks to brian bowers for signing
up on my website you are new member
number 20. we are now able to accept
gifted memberships on my website
four people have paid for gifted
subscriptions
and 76 people have requested gifted
subscriptions okay
so we're going to have to
figure that out
um
now let me see how we will we'll email
people after the stream okay to give
away those those free ones that's what
we'll do i can't think of any other way
to do it
also thanks to evan lutt's music for the
twitch prime subscription let's listen
to a few voicemails it's been quite a
long weekend um and we have so many
voicemails that came in
certainly some of them are from whitney
so i was reading or watching um why on
on youtube um it's like this indian
channel that's um
like worlds
it is one or something like that
um and then we're saying that
it was prince charles
i don't even know what she's talking
about and i would also uh repute that
you state that i have a five-year
race
calling
racism this is troy york denying that
he's been sending racist calls for five
years i'll leave your program
when my favorite podcasters are
typically black males of officer tayden
or anthony brian logan who the cowardly
david pacman would never debate who's
anthony brian logan i know brian tyler
cohen i know john wayne
gacy but who who is anthony and what did
he say anthony brian logan
man i don't know what he's talking about
so the middle east
made the bible and they made the
redheads that came from the caves
and they wanted to preach about like
ignorance and how like the mistreatment
of slaves and stuff like that like
people weren't allowed to have slaves
when they leaked it to europe
wow
man yeah this is uh troy york y o
r k
um do you smear me i'm
um
that's all you political about this um
when you have no argument um
when you don't want to discuss the facts
and the truth
that can cheat out jackson is
her name's not conchita oh man
um
okay
i want to
let's see here oh okay so more people
gifted some subscriptions
wait what is going on here this is crazy
okay i have a few more gifted
subscriptions to give away brian
wrestler jarrett osterreich clark
jody bundrick and another one from brian
wrestler i have four more gifted website
subscriptions and they are going to
this is just an order that people
request them
i hope i pronounced that correctly
john roberts
josh zemian
and kaden nelson okay we've had 81 free
memberships requested eight of those
have been funded so we have a lot of
unfunded liabilities here and that's
okay
in the order people request the
memberships at davidpakman.com
free membership we will give them away
after the stream i'll email you
with a code that you can use to sign up
okay so we're gonna we're gonna do that
um
and i have to tell you
if you want us to give away the
membership when you go through the gift
process on our website don't enter in
any recipient because if you do that we
won't be able to give it away okay very
very important
also
brian ressler
and brian steen gifting another two
which will allow me to give away a
membership to jeremy kerr
and hudson markle
okay oh and wow brian ressler giving
away another one brian's an all-star
that will allow me to give one away to
ivan valdez
this is great
wow we're really giving be able to give
away a lot of these this this is
fantastic
this is fantastic
um
okay
i'm trying to make sure i'm all caught
up with this stuff i think so
thanks also to uh half cabbage gmuck
bazzy on twitch and then chef ramsay who
gifted six putting us at 34.
um
okay
and brian wrestler gifting another one
wow brian wrestler gifting number 35
which means i can give another
membership away to laura roberts laura
thank you very much or i guess
congratulations you're the recipient
let's keep going with voicemails as we
await joe biden here i do have a lot of
them
um
let's see who we've got here man whitney
is just calling relentlessly
so
see how
when um
when jewish people become like part of
our society they like embellish
like what we're doing and her presence
and stuff like that horribly
anti-semitic what she's saying
uh mr pacman if you think that uh
joe biden and president administration
which i assume would be a very busy one
and if they meant met for 30 minutes
with tick-tock influencers
and if you think that there was no
exchange of money
no exchange of money discussed then yeah
there was no guys it was a zoom call
there's people who are saying that the
biden administration quote paid off
tick-tockers to promote their view on
ukraine first of all
99 of the world has the same view on
ukraine biden doesn't have to pay people
to convince them russia's in the wrong
that's that's number one and number two
it was a zoom call there's no evidence
whatsoever that the biden administ
administration
paid tick-tockers to get on a zoom call
now if they had traveled to dc you might
be able to say well they prob maybe they
paid for the travel
it was a zoom call guys that's it
they didn't pay anybody give me a break
give me a break
devoe has gifted another website
membership which i am able to give away
to brian spurlock if you want to request
a free membership on my website go to
davidpakman.com free membership if you
want to gift a membership on my website
go through the normal sign up process
and then check the box that says this is
a gift
this is a gift
very easy to do
uh all right let's listen to a couple
other voicemails i'm trying to get to
something that's not troy york or
whitney okay here's troll man also known
as juan i say juan
i don't pretend to not understand
spanish you know people say my name's
juan
dude give me a break it's juan
hey david it's swan again um i have a
question i hope you can answer it please
what's wrong with
conceding to the republicans
that
any type of
lgbtq
education etc etc etc
not be given
talked about et cetera
for children
that are
between the grades of first and sixth
grade yeah it's insane because what the
bill does in florida is prevent teachers
from even acknowledging oh
there's two daddies here
okay
and
if you issue such a blanket ban really
teachers shouldn't be allowed a
heterosexual female teacher shouldn't be
allowed to say that she has a male
husband because either way you're
talking about gender and relationships
so
it's it it's absolutely idiotic if you
really take it to its full conclusion
um
i'm getting emails from people asking
for free memberships unfortunately those
are going into the trash guys
there is only one way to ask for a free
membership and it's to fill out the form
at davidpakman.com
free membership they're going to be
given away in the order that people
request them if you email me asking for
a membership it's going in the trash we
can't it there's too many people
interested to be able to do that
okay so for example lauren morris just
gifted a subscription on our website
and that subscription goes to andrew
thompson
do people understand how this is working
in the order that we have them to give
away
we give them to people in the order that
they request them
you can't email if you email it things
get crazy also thanks to kyla ballen
for signing up for a membership for
herself
at joinedpakman.com
and lastly thanks to gmuk for gifting a
subscription on twitch i really
appreciate that
let's see what else we've got in the
voicemail area
uh oh boy so i noticed all you [ __ ]
british anarchists are in one spot
looking for help from nato
just so you know
this looks like a big [ __ ] anarchist
[ __ ]
you're like being typed as like
a [ __ ] grandma but you're a [ __ ]
wolf
yeah all right here is president joe
biden
good afternoon everyone oh god that's
very low grateful to be here with the
president as we release his budget for
next year
as the director of the office of
management and budget i deal with a lot
of numbers and charts and graphs and
they all matter
but that's not ultimately what budgets
are about
budgets are valuable to be here
they're about the kind of country we
want to be and the type of future we
want to leave our kids
and from day one the president has been
clear that my job as omb director is to
ensure that the government delivers for
all people
and that our budget reflects our
national values and priorities
i'm proud to say that's exactly what
this budget does
invest in the american people in a
fiscally responsible way
this budget will help ensure that
prosperity the prosperity is broadly
shared that we continue growing the
economy from the bottom up in the middle
out
that we make sure it works for working
americans who've been left out and left
behind who haven't benefit from the
economic progress they help make
possible
that we are prepared to meet the full
range of challenges and opportunities
ahead of us
and it's a budget that includes
proposals all americans can come
together around and that speak to our
country's values at its best
and that's why it's my honor to
introduce the president of the united
states joe biden
all right
let's listen
big big deal
well good afternoon folks
been a busy couple days
for all of you
the um
let me begin by saying that thanking
director young
you know you've heard me say this before
over the years
my dad had an expression he said don't
tell me what you value
the subtitles don't seem to be working
so we'll go over here let me begin by
saying that thanking
director young
you know you've heard me say this before
over the years
my dad had an expression he said don't
tell me what you value
show me your budget i'll tell you what
you value right
don't tell me what you value show me
your budget and i'll tell you what you
value
well the budget i'm releasing today
sends a clear message to the american
people that we've what we value first
fiscal responsibility
second safety and security and thirdly
the in shooting and investments needed
to build a better america
the first value is fiscal responsibility
the previous administration as you all
know ran up record budget deficits
in fact the deficit went up every year
under my predecessor
my administration is turning that around
last year we cut the deficit by more
than 350 billion dollars
this year on track to cut the deficit by
more than 1 trillion
three hundred billion dollars
one trillion three hundred billion
dollars
that would be the largest one-year
reduction in the deficit in u.s history
and here's how we're achieving this
record deficit reduction
first we're growing the economy
we've created a record 6.7 million jobs
since i took office
and we've generated a gdp growth of 5.7
the best economic growth we've seen in
this country in over 40 years
this has led to substantial increase in
government revenues and dramatically
improved our fiscal situation
secondly this record economic and job
growth has made it possible for us to
responsibly and significantly cut back
on emergency spending
early in the pandemic
it was right to give people help to make
ends meet and keep their account this
economy going
because
of the progress we've made
dealing with these emergencies the labor
market is strong and unemployment
unemployment claims are at historic lows
we entered the pandemic unemployment
assistance programs because americans
are back to work i'm calling for new
pandemic subsidies for large businesses
to not continue those because those
businesses are back and moving again as
well so
because we have to put this economy in a
strong foundation
even the delta and omicron variants of
covet 19
and the cost of putin's aggression in
ukraine have not required additional an
additional fiscal package for state and
local governments
but we still spend what we need to spend
to continue to fight covet
but those expenditures will be
dramatically less than last year
compared to 2020 we're reducing the size
of the deficit
relative our economy by almost
two-thirds reducing inflationary
pressures and making real headway
cleaning up the fiscal mess i inherited
after my president's my my my
predecessor's fiscal
mismanagement
we were reducing the trump deficits and
returning our fiscal house to order
now the budget i'm releasing today
will continue this approach it makes
prudent investments in economic growth
and more equitable economy while making
sure corporations and the very wealthy
pay their fair share and i would add
nobody making less than 400 000 a year
will pay a penny more in federal taxes
okay
we can do this by one passing
legislation that lowers costs for
families on things like child care
health care and energy costs
while lowering our deficit at the same
time we can give hard-working parents
raising children tax relief that gives
them just a little bit of breathing room
and lowers child poverty
we can give medicare the power to
negotiate lower prescription drug prices
this will bring down the cost for
seniors and reduce the deficit by
hundreds of billions of dollars
congress can do this this all right now
they're debating it now
we can also restore fiscal
responsibility
the trump tax cuts added two trillion
dollars in deficit spending and largely
helped the rich and the largest
corporations
under my plan as i said no one making
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year
will pay
additional single penny in taxes no one
if you don't make 400 grand you're not
going to pay a single penny an
additional
oh boy
all right
percent that's the average they pay
now i'm a capitalist but uh just i want
i if you make a billion bucks great
just pay your fair share pay a little
bit a firefighter and a teacher
pay more than double
double the tax rate that a billionaire
pays
that's not right
that's not fair
and my budget contains a billionaire
minimum tax because of that with 20
minimum tax it applies only to the top
100th of one percent that's the 101 of
the americans will pay this tax
the billionaire minimum tax is fair and
it raises 360 billion dollars that can
be used to lower costs for families and
cut the deficit
as i said my budget also ensures the
corporations pay their fair share
in 2020 for 50 fortune 500 companies
that made 40 billion dollars in profit
combined but didn't pay a single
solitary cent in federal taxes
my budget raises the corporate tax rate
to 28 percent
far lower than the rate it was between
world war ii and 2017 when it was
lowered
as of today
last year
i rallied more than 100 some of you were
overseas with me 130 countries to agree
to a global minimum tax for corporations
doing the business in the in their
countries to put an end to a tax system
that rewards multinational corporations
for shipping the jobs and profits
overseas and avoiding taxes at home
it's my hope that congress can access
law this year so i can sign it and we
can get to work
the second value my budget reflects is
security
security at home and security abroad
my brother my budget tackles security in
two key ways
first
it secures our communities at home
this is an issue families in every part
of the country face
i've said it before
the answer is not to defund our police
departments it's to fund our police and
give them all the tools they need
training
and foundation
and partners and protectors in our that
our communities need
the budget puts more police on the
street for community policing so they
get to know the community they're
policing
allows the bureau of alcohol to back on
firearms and the fbi to hire the agents
they need to help fight gun crime and
other violent crimes in our communities
and funds body cameras and make sure
police work with our local communities
and are accountable to these communities
it funds crime prevention and community
violence intervention
drug treatment mental health criminal
justice reform and re-entry for people
coming home after incarceration
all demonstrable ways to reduce crime in
proven ways
security also means national and
international security
this budget provides the resources we
need to keep americans safe
ensuring that our military remains the
best prepared
best trained
best-equipped military in the world
this budget also provides additional
funding
to forcefully respond to putin's
aggression against ukraine and its
economic humanitarian just remember guys
the president's bus budget is a
political document it's sort of a wish
list it's that that's all it is trump's
budgets were never passed just being up
front here competition from other nation
states
china and russia which are going to
require investments to make things like
space and cyber and other advanced
capabilities including including
hypersonics
and this will be among the largest
investments in our national security in
history some people don't like the
increase but we're in a different world
today
america is more prosperous more
successful and more just when it is more
secure
we can restore fiscal responsibility and
safeguard our security at home and
abroad while meeting a third value what
i call building a better america
let's provide universal preschool
cap the cost of child care at seven
percent
of a family's income
like many families that would cut the
cost of child care in half
let's make it'll make college more
affordable my budget doubles the maximum
pell grant
the people families making under fifty
thousand dollars a year to nearly
thirteen thousand dollars
and helps more than eight million
students who rely on pell grants pay for
college
my budget invests in building more home
to keep us up to deal with the
skyrocketing cost of housing for the
middle class and the poor
my budget lowers family energy costs
with tax credits help people make their
homes more efficient
research and development to broaden the
versus the reach of solar and build a
clean energy future
my budget also invests in other areas of
bipartisan common good
i call them unity agendas i spoke to
them at the state of the union
beating the opioid the opioid epidemic
taking on challenges of mental health
supporting our veterans
and ending cancer as we know it
this budget includes investments to get
americans the mental health services
they need and we need them
and when it comes to fighting cancer and
other diseases yeah between this budget
and trump's new health care plan which
is coming out in the next two weeks
we've really got a lot of stuff
happening
and it stands for advanced research
projects for health
it's based on darpa the defense
department program that led to
breakthroughs and technologies like the
internet gps and so much more
rph will drive breakthroughs to prevent
detect and treat diseases
including alzheimer's diabetes cancers
and more
and here's what this all adds up to
historic deficit reduction
historic investment in our security at
home and abroad
by modernizing our capabilities in both
areas
an unprecedented commitment to building
an economy where everyone has a chance
to
succeed a plan to pay for those
investments that we need as a nation
that's what we do
so i look forward to working with the
members of congress democrats
republicans independents to deliver this
budget and keep the living for the
american people i want to thank you all
and god bless you all and god protect
our troops
let me uh
kelly o'donnell nbc here we go thank you
mr president do you believe what you
let's see if here we can see
[Music]
kelly o'donnell nbc
thank you mr president do you believe
what you said
thank you sir do you believe what you
said that putin can't remain in power or
do you now regret saying that because
your government has been trying to walk
that back did your words complicate
matters
well you asked three different questions
i'll answer them all number one i'm not
walking anything back
the fact of the matter is i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
toward the way putin is
dealing and the actions of this man
just just
brutality
half the children in ukraine i just come
from
being with those families
and uh and so but i want to make it
clear i wasn't then nor am i now
articulating the policy change i was
expressing the moral outrage that i feel
and i make no apologies for it
personal feelings
secondly you asked me about uh
well what was the second part complicate
the diplomacy of this moment no i don't
think it does you know the the uh
the fact is that we're in a situation
where uh
um
what complicates the situation at the
moment is the
uh the escalatory
efforts of putin
to uh continue to engage in carnage the
kind of behavior that
that makes the whole world say my god
what is this man doing
that's what complicates things a great
deal and uh
but i i don't think it complicates at
all
let me go to steve hall reuters mr
president thank you when you say that
you're not walking anything back you do
feel that vladimir putin should be
remained from removed from power is that
what you're saying no what i was i was
expressing just what i said i was
expressing the more outrage i felt
towards this man i wasn't articulating a
policy change
and
i think that
you know he continues on this course
that he's on
he is going to become a pariah worldwide
and who knows what he'd come becomes at
home in terms of support
are you concerned this remark might
escalate the conflict no i'm not
i'm not at all
look
and you know look the other thing is
that uh
a couple people have asked me as well
might well speak to unless you want to
ask putin should not be in power is
different than we're going to remove
putin from power i mean they're just two
different things
uh no
and as weak in nato
no it hadn't
nato has never ever ever ever ever ever
been as strong as it is today
never
[Music]
it means that i would hope
i just it was expressing my outrage he
shouldn't remain in power just like you
know bad people shouldn't continue to do
bad things there you go it doesn't mean
we have a fundamental policy to do
anything to take putin down in any way
what made you add that because that
wasn't in your prepared remarks we were
told so what made you add that at the
end mr president because i was talking
about i was talking to them to the
russian people the last part of the
speech was talking to the russian people
telling what we thought
i have no problem with what biden said
nor with people asking him to clarify
it's fine
this is just stating a simple fact
that
this kind of behavior
is totally unacceptable
totally unacceptable and the way to deal
with it is to strengthen and
put
keep nato
completely
united and help ukraine where we can
uh cleve you had a question
where is he
uh thanks mr president
um on your on your budget uh
you you said repeatedly at the state of
the union that you're not for defunding
the police i i do wonder how much
emphasis you think should be put on
alternative forms of crime prevention
not just defending the police but uh you
know crime reduction in communities oh a
significant amount i've laid that out in
detail in the budget that's an example
of like no i don't think we should put
any any money into that kind of a you
know a silly question police need they
they need psychologists in the
department as much as they need extra
rifles they need people who are in the
department who can deal with the crisis
that the police are going through as
well
dealing with their crises did they deal
with their mental state and how they're
handling things they need out they need
social workers engaged with them i lay
it all out there's a
and it all works and you see these
community intervention programs they
work they actually reduce crime they
significantly reduce crime so that's a
big piece of it it's a follow-up is any
is any of it related to political
pressure from republicans saying that
democrats are soft on crime that you
know that you guys are creating to the
left and that kind of fascinating when i
first got elected i was being beat up
because i supported the police too much
for the previous 30 years
no
that's what i think um get vaccinated um
osmo
surprisingly called thank you mr
president
um
are you
are you willing to try to meet with
vladimir putin and i have a quick
follow-up to that when you last met with
him face-to-face in geneva you had
described that as a productive
conversation you said that he did not
want a cold war
and do you feel
given the actions though that have
happened over the last few months i
guess i'm asking what has changed
in his mind
i don't know what's changed his mind his
behavior has changed
when we met remember what we're talking
about we're talking about setting up a
strategic dialogue
and talking about the relationship of
nato and russia and facing off in the
regions and how we could have more
transparency and all the rest it was a
normal discussion i had going all the
way back to kissigan and others back in
100 years ago when i was a young senator
and so what changed was
nothing nothing remotely approaching
that remember when he first met with he
said i have two objectives this is the
second or third time i met with him
he said i have two objectives one is to
make sure that that they never become
part of nato and two to make sure there
are no
long-range missiles in there in ukraine
i said we could deal with the second one
easily but we can't close the door on
the on the first
because when we talk about missiles we
want to talk about what's also on the
russian border heading toward europe do
both
and uh
and then if you notice that demand list
of his or not with me with others have
escalated significantly in terms of what
he thinks is is necessary
thank you for uh
thank you thank you very much i know
you're gonna ask a really nice question
well it's an important question i think
are you worried that other leaders in
the world are gonna start to doubt that
america is back if some of these big
things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
once can you walk back it made it sound
like just in the last couple days uh it
sounded like you told us troops they
were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like what you were calling
for regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred right none of
the three none of the three mr president
you interpret the language that way i
was talking to the troops we were
talking about helping train the troops
in that are the the ukrainian troops
that are in poland that's with the
context i sat there with those guys for
a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with speaking with
and talking with the
ukrainian troops or in poland and when
you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in kind
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
why would i tell you you've got to be
silly
the world wants to know the world wants
to know a lot of things i'm not telling
them what the response would be then
then russia knows the response
all right
i'm going to take two more questions one
two
thank you
um i still want to get back to your
original words that he cannot remain in
power
can you help us understand you have more
foreign policy experience than any
president who's ever held this office
whether those are your personal feelings
or your feelings as president you
understand why people would believe you
as someone commanding one of the largest
nuclear arsenals in the world saying
someone cannot remain in power is a
statement of u.s policy and also are you
concerned about propaganda use of those
remarks by the russians
no and
tell me why you have so much experience
you are the leader of this country
because it's ridiculous
nobody believes we're gonna take down i
was gonna i was talking about taking
down putin
nobody believes that
number one number two what have i been
talking about
off since this all began
the only war that's worse than one
intended is one that's unintended the
last thing i want to do is engage in a
land war or a nuclear war with russia
that's not honestly how many times do
they have to ask the same question
behavior of this man
it's outrageous it's outrageous
and
it's more an aspiration anything he
shouldn't be in power
there's no i mean people like this
shouldn't be ruling countries but they
do
the fact they do but guys duterte
shouldn't be in power bolsonaro
shouldn't be in power putin shouldn't be
but i don't want the u.s removing them
efforts but just to be clear are you
confident that vladimir putin sees it
that way that he will not use this as an
escalatory uh i don't care what he
thinks look here's the he's going to do
what he's going to do
put look but you're not concerned that
he may see your language and view that
as a sign of a reason for escalation use
that as an excuse to escalate given his
recent behavior
given his recent behavior you should
excuse me i shouldn't say that to you
given his recent behavior people should
understand that he is going to do what
he thinks he should do period
he's not affected by anybody else
including unfortunately apparently his
own advisors
this is a guy who goes to the beat of
his own drummer and the idea that he is
going to do something outrageous because
i called him for what he was and what
he's doing i think it's just not
rational oh
never again it depends no it's not a
question the question is is there
something to meet on that would justify
him being able to end this war and be
able to rebuild ukraine that's the issue
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president whether or not you would be
willing to meet with president it
depends on what he wants to talk about
thank you okay last question um
what if you wanted to talk about
negotiations now what if you want you
said supreme court i don't call you well
you can't leave that hanging
just real quick um
two matters on the supreme court there
while you were away um
there were reports about the wife of
justice thomas
uh and texts that she had with former
chief of staff mark meadows should
justice thomas recuse himself from any
cases involving the january 6
insurrection or former president trump
at this point i'll leave that to two
entities
okay go ahead i'll go ahead and ask the
second question no two entities go ahead
sorry
one
the january 6th committee and to the
justice department that's their judgment
not mine so on justice thomas recusing
you don't think he should or i'm not i
said that i told you those things get
into legal issues that in fact i told
you i would not tell the justice
department what position it takes or not
take there and i'm not going to instruct
the congress either and did you get any
chance to watch
much of the judiciary committee here
you see any of it
um the fact that republicans were
questioning
judge jackson on matters like former
sentences related to child pornography
cases or the definition of a woman
does that does the former chairman of
the judiciary committee make sense to
you
look this is one of the most qualified
nominees ever
nominated for the supreme court true in
every respect
in terms of her disposition
her intellectual capacity
her experience and background and
serving on two three
additional courts a woman who is totally
thoroughly qualified
totally thoroughly qualified it'll be a
great addition to the court in my view
thank you
and there goes joseph biden jr the
president of the united states uh taking
i would say he took a dozen questions he
really took three questions but a couple
of the questions were asked like 10
times
um
we are going to be banning a bunch of
really annoying people um
some guy just came in and said hey so
you're basically hassan without memes
huh you're banned i don't need you here
just go away go watch go watch hassan or
whatever i mean i just don't care uh all
right very very important announcements
of all sorts i want to say thanks to see
missile manor mom and under the screen
putting us at 42
for the day
also thank you to adam gingrich
and adam gingrich gifting two
subscriptions which i will be able to
give away to timothy djukovic
and kelvin priest if you want a free
membership on my website request it at
davidpakman.com
free membership
155 memberships have been requested
thanks to the generosity of today's
viewers i will be able to gift 16
and people will get emails in the next
hour or two with information on how to
claim those i already
gave the names of the first
16.
um that's going to do it for today thank
you for joining me and we will be back
very very soon